après columbia challenger c'est demain
soir en direct dans notre journal que la
deuxième navette spatiale américaine
décollera enfin après les cinq vols
réussis de columbia challenger prend la
relève du programme spatial américain
avec un équipage de quatre hommes et ce
pour une mission de cinq jours georges
leclercq
oui prêt à partir sur son pas de tir à
cap canaveral voici en effet challenger
la nouvelle navette spatiale américaine
son équipage vient d'arriver le
décollage est prévu pour demain soir
enfin pourrait-on dire car la soeur de
columbia connu bien des problèmes depuis
sa sortie des usines notamment lors d'un
essai des moteurs en décembre dernier
une fuite détectée il faut changer
complètement un moteur et réparer les
deux autres la mission regarder lancé un
très gros satellite de
télécommunications aux commandes de
challenger un vétéran paul weiss qui a
séjourné un mois dans l'espace à bord de
skylab en -73 son pilote carol bove qu
est un bleu le médecin de bord storim
aux grèves
l'ingénieur donne peterson aussi ce sont
eux qui vont sortir avec les nouveau
scaphandre que leurs collègues du vol
précédent n'avait pas pu faire
fonctionner ils travailleront dans le
vide de la soute de challenger lors du
quatrième vol nouveau challenger lors de
l'atterrissage le pilote et le
commandant regarder vers ont des
indications précises sur leurs vols
directement sur la vitre autre nouveauté
les tuiles de protection thermique
utilisé lors du retour sont densifiés et
plus résistantes
les blacks nouvelle recouvre les moteurs
de manoeuvre situé à l'arrière
tout cela contribue à alléger challenger
par rapport à sa grande soeur columbia
de plus d'une tonne
un dernier mot rappelons en rappelant
que si tout va bien le décollage est
pour demain soir à l' usine qui fabrique
les navettes spatiales au nord de los
angeles
une future navette est presque prêt
presque terminé c'est discovery dans le
premier vol est en principe prévu au
début de l'année prochaine